I have to have a pretty girl if she's
got no clothes on that's even better I
work for Playboy I've been doing that
for 15 years but I was the creator of
the Cheerios B long long ago I remember
it as one of the earliest things I did
the bee that I drew I thought it would
be kind of fun to do one that looked
more like a bee so I gave him big
compound eyes and antennas and that
wasn't at all what they wanted they
thought he was a little too insect like
and insects and cereals probably not a
good combination
but he eventually ended up looking like
he does now we put shoes on which I
didn't have in the beginning oh and they
gave him a sweater so he was wearing
something so it really is more like a
Disney character than than an insect yes
I always say looks like Elmer Fudd in a
suit the face became more human he got a
little nose of course and eyes with
pupils no compound eyes why what is it
with the eyes well the eyes are the main
thing when you do a cartoon character
you want to focus on the eyes after all
and if you can have eyebrows and eyes
with pupils you need something that can
be expressive
now you work for Playboy yes yes half
said he liked my lady in the [__] eyes
I try to keep things a little innocent
[Music]
[Laughter]
you
[Music]